let's get it rolling
man your [ __ ] youtube's blowing man
i just didn't hit 2 million that's crazy
that's crazy
she's crazy i thought i was going to
have about 30 people watching this
crazy show now you got 2 million
i like that concrete [ __ ] too i always
watch those what's that one dude's name
that uh
he [ __ ] uh he mortgaged a bunch of
houses matthew cox
yeah he's he's a beast i love this [ __ ]
he's awesome
all right jimmy how's it going i'm so
happy to see you again yeah i'm glad i'm
glad to be here you called me this
morning with some great news
yes sir tell me what's going on well i'm
booking my flight to get out of la
to ready to go to treatment that's
awesome got in contact with a nice
treatment center you know and they're
ready to take me in no insurance
to help me out you know thankfully to
you you know
i'm pretty much just ready to get you
out of here ready to get my journey of
recovery
you're young 20 23 23. dude
all i can tell you is this is this will
be the the most important
best thing you ever do in your life yeah
sure because everything you do from here
on
out will will play out differently
because yeah
if you're able to get clean yeah it's
like trading up one thing for everything
you know
it's literally that's how i think of it
you know trade away the drugs for
my life back and and just understand
there'll be lots of relapses lots of
setbacks but
it's just it's it's part of moving up
and down yeah yeah
but now yeah i'm writing your story
really hit me hard because
it's like you remind me like a young
version of me yeah but you're
you're stuck in quicksand and like i
wanted to give you a handout but it's
not that easy
[ __ ] you're you've done it because you
have to do the work i can do all the
work in the world but it's not going to
help you
so yeah i'm ready you know i've seen
what happened so many times where i'm
like here
let me help you let me give you this
that and the other so you can get out
and nobody does
yeah and [ __ ] it i mean i'm ready to do
it you know
what kind of helped you turn the corner
on this the way you see it i mean like
you're just tired of being down here
i'm just tired of living this life bro
i'm like i'm ready to get my life back
and have fun you know and
go out and meet real friends and like
you know go
do [ __ ] i'm supposed to do and get a job
and like live with actual life you know
get a career go to school you know like
i'm done [ __ ] sitting around getting
high and just [ __ ] you know sobbing
like
that shit's over with like you know like
i'm so ready to get this started i'm so
happy
yeah fentanyl is a tough drug to to
break free of i'm sure yeah it is
definitely
you know i've tried plenty of times to
get off of it but like i i always
ended up staying in la and now you know
i'm getting a whole new scenery which
you know and like i think it's going to
be great for me you know
yeah well anything getting out of skid
row is
this is just it's impossible to get
clean if you're if you're here exactly
and uh
you talk to your family about this or
anything like that yeah yeah my father
was really happy for me yeah
i still keep in contact with both my
parents i haven't told my mother yet but
um
my dad yeah definitely this girl i'm
talking to she's happy for me
you know she's really happy for me ready
to do this
but yeah you know of course my family's
gonna be supportive they want me to do
the best you know they
they really do you know yeah i'm ready
to you know
you're such a great kid you have so much
potential thank you you
you're so sensible and it's just like
it's tragic that
you might be stuck here for the rest of
your life doing this yeah yeah
sorry you know i'm ready to make this
change and you know just never look back
you know it's done done that's my ends
which man like
last straw how long you've been using
fentanyl about
uh three to four to five years almost oh
my god
the day my brother died that's not the
first time i started you know my older
brother from chrome disease
which i talked about last time yeah so
you know no there'll be things that
stress you out and and
and make you want to use again but you
just
have to steer clear of that yeah i think
i'm you know i think i'm just
straight up i think i can do it you know
i have real confidence in this time you
know i'm
just done with it you know it's not fun
anymore it's not
it's just wasted my money and waste of
time
you know like i could do so much better
[ __ ]
you know and progress and you know make
money and own a business or do something
you know anything yeah
live a life yeah this is not fun sitting
out here in skid row getting high it's
not worth it
what advice would you give to a young
person who's playing around with
harder drugs um i'll tell a man just
you know think about your family you
know like you know you can die any day
doing that [ __ ] you know
any day i've seen so many people die out
here every day for like the last month
somebody's done it's insane you know
just [ __ ]
trade that [ __ ] it's not worth it you
know like you literally just got to give
up that
one that one thing that addiction to get
your whole life back
and trading everything for one thing i
think it's a fair trade you know
and just [ __ ] yeah it might be a
choice that first time you try it but it
never
it's not a choice you can ever make ever
again because once you're addicted
it's become so difficult to stop yeah
it's it's it's
it's it's not fun man it's just gonna
lead it's just gonna get worse and worse
you know
if you you know it's just gonna get
worse and worse it's not gonna get
better
it's not you know you know the height is
not gonna feel as good
when you keep doing it it's just going
to be pointless you know
and eventually you're going to run out
of money unless you can function and you
know work but a lot of addicts i
don't you know it's hard to even get a
job or keep a job for them you know
it's it's hard to do much of anything
except yeah exactly
get your fix and go home and usually
they're [ __ ]
doing you know stealing or doing
something bad to get their fix you know
what what what goals do or did you have
for your life
before drugs kind of derailed you goals
i really wanted to go to trade school
and figure out something that i love to
do
which i still haven't figured out what i
really want to but i think i might look
into
you know like the recovery uh thing you
know once i get my stuff
together and get enough clean time you
know and talk to to
for advocate for youth and stuff you
know you'd be great adolescence you know
i wanna help kids you know because you
know my little brother means everything
to me you know
everything you know and like you know i
don't like you know
if i can help any kid you know just by
speaking to them and telling my story
let's do it you know ready
that's amazing jimmy your story is is so
heartwarming to hear because yeah
so many people yeah i assume the
comments are amazing man i cry reading
them you know so much support and i
love everyone that you know just even
takes the time to comment to tell me how
they feel and
tell me to you know keep pushing like
appreciate them all you know
it means a lot more to me than they
think i read them every day you know
and then really you know that that's
actually that whole thing has
played a big part of me just doing this
you know getting ready to get out you
know
the comments helped you yeah you know
because i
didn't know how many people like cared
you know like actually like they really
do i can tell like
i get a lot of messages you know and
it's just nothing but
heartwarming like you know you know like
[ __ ]
just like keep doing like pushing me you
know pushing me telling me i can do it
you know
you know that would be amazing if if if
youtube comments got you to
it's crazy get off your eyes bro i
really really cry every time i read them
you know it's like
you know i damn like people like people
praying for me you know it's like crazy
like i don't know i
i know i could do good because you know
i know i can do it you know
just gotta [ __ ] do it it's very clear
i just met you just a month ago or
whenever we shot that
yeah and it's so clear even that in that
first meeting that you're such a great
kid you have so much potential
thank you you just got your foot stuck
in this trap
yeah yeah like i said in the first one
it doesn't discriminate you know
and like i wish i never picked it up but
you know
once i get clean it's a part of my life
story you know and i can help others
after
i'm sure you see people down here that
you know and yeah and i wish i could
help
but you know a lot of them they don't
want to help you know they're not either
they say they do but they but they're
not really ready they're just
just helping yourself you're gonna take
it's gonna take everything you got
yeah it's gonna i'm taking one step at a
time you know day by day because it's
gonna be a daily fight you know to you
know
that's how it you've been in a rehab
before
yeah a bunch of times i've been a nice
nice treatment center as you know and
it's just but i've always came back to
la you know
they're all in la all the treatment
centers i've been to yeah you know i get
some
like like i said i got a couple months
clean go to a sober house
be bored have some money in my pocket no
no i can get drugs downtown oh
take a bus downtown there's my relapse
yeah but there are drugs everywhere
yeah you can find them any city in the
country yeah
definitely skid row is a free open
market of it but yeah
but even in you know yeah anywhere yeah
definitely anywhere you can find them in
delaware you can find them in north
dakota you can find them anywhere
exactly
but i'm ready to just i'm gonna i'm
gonna stay away from that crowd you know
i'm gonna stay with with people who want
me to do good and you know like my
mentors and
people who want to push me to do better
and and do like legal
legal life you know have a good look and
have life you know so i can have kids
and [ __ ] and have a wife
tired of this [ __ ] you'd be a great
father i'm sure yeah
great great husband or boyfriend
well jimmy i'm so happy for you and i
can't wait to hear
how you're doing in in your rehab and
thank you so much i hope we do another
interview and you're
yeah definitely doing it i'm definitely
gonna have to
got to you know you're you're a big part
of my story honestly you know like
if i didn't do the interview honestly i
probably wouldn't be doing this you know
that's great and with the talks we have
like your motivation you give me like
you know like
yeah you've come by a few times after
that first interview and it's it's just
heartbreaking to like
see you on the street and i can see i
could say i could hear every time i see
you that you're starting to come around
and it's like
yeah there's so much stress but it's
it's all on you it's not me
yeah i can want it i can throw a million
dollars at you and tell you go to rehab
yeah that one that won't do it wouldn't
do nothing yeah
yep yeah i'm making the big step and you
know
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna you know
it's gonna take time it's gonna take
hard work i know that you know yep
you can do it though yep definitely
awesome jimmy thank you so much for
coming back and i'm really proud of you
yeah thank you mark i appreciate it okay
man good luck you too
you